Oh, dusk quick Chinese lesson, just for fun.
This is a character for peace, right?
So that is
[inaudible]. Okay. So that is pronounced this way.
Second tongue ping, UN, okay.
This means level or even,
so if you had say pink June, if you had pink, June,
June is, would be this character a little sloppy,
but you get the idea June. That would be average. Okay.
Like the average the mean, okay, so pink,
June ping UN is peace.
And just to show you how this character is
constructed, some people will love this. Some people won't, but this is a roof,
this radical on the top, and this is a woman underneath.
So a woman under a roof in a home means peace or peaceful,
and you can construct other characters really easily using the second one.
Just to give you an idea. So you might have, for instance,
that's boom, it's a little sloppy,
but you get the idea on which means public.
Uh,
and it means so public safety, public security,
that's also kind of a police officer. All right. So,
and then you could have own UN [inaudible] park. All right.
So you got public peace.
You have sort of even peace means at peace.
No. Cause for worry, et cetera.
Hope that is interesting to some of you have a beautiful day.